this is a girl is a few months old but
she has no name
none of the babies in this special unit
do these are Athens abandoned children
their parents have left them but the
hospital hope they will come back some
do most don't
Olivia a node is at the left there who
near discrete in truth the problem has
increased many women give birth here and
then just leave the hospital leaving
their child here for us to look after
one reason is that there are mothers who
believe they can't bring up their child
so they leave them here after swimming
the other reason because of the wave
immigrants a phenomena the staff here
are very protective they will look after
the babies until they're about six
months old and then hand them on to an
orphanage or to care some children are
taken into care because their parents
can no longer afford to look after them
to clothe them to feed them to bring
them up but they're the few for most
children it's because their parents have
become alcoholics or abusers or they're
drug addicts or because they've
committed suicide and that is the
indirect consequence of the economic
crisis in Greece some of the children
the slightly older ones end up here a
home in a suburb of Athens run by
Greece's largest children's charity
there are refuge for abused children
havens for young boys and girls whose
parents have just disappeared in ten
days time though they will run out of
money Greece's financial problems have
meant that people have stopped donating
we never dare to think that it will do
so that's why we try very hard to
persuade people but the club people from
overseas that concept make you feel it's
never said it's it's an idea of a little
boy started 20 years ago from a son who
before he died and this come realistic
now and we have the native children are
expecting us to continue their lives so
there's no way we can abandon this a
second time
these are the unwanted children of
Greece the human consequence of an
economic crisis that began before they
were even born
alistair bungle skynews Athens